take some vitamin d blend yourself up a
delicious meat smoothie and settle in
for some good ol east coast hospitality
get the [ __ ] out of here
out of this town they're gonna munch on
your balls i just want the crystal of
set
you
sure after over a year and a half since
season nine's 1984 we finally have
season 10 double feature and i don't
know about you guys but this was the
best start to an ahs i've seen in a long
time and there is a lot to unpack in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive
into episodes 1 and 2 theories on the
pale creatures what can actually stop
them and where the story is headed not
to mention connections to the greater
ahs universe warning there will be
spoilers for episodes 1 and 2 and
sleuthing with footage from the released
previews but before we begin be sure to
like and subscribe as i'll be covering
every episode of the season welcome to
provincetown massachusetts where the men
are pale and the roadkill plentiful here
we'll see our protagonist harry gardner
played by ahs alum finn whitrock
alongside his wife doris and daughter
alma they stomp along the road where it
appears that deer has been ripped apart
by some sort of creature now if you've
listened to the radio program kpcd 666
that fx has released over the last few
days i'll leave a link to the first
chapter in the description you'll know
that large roadkill has been spotted
around town which is curious since all
the bears should be hibernating doris
also brings up lyme disease here
something she'll bring up several times
throughout the episode and even
investigate on her laptop you don't want
to get lime there's lyme disease all
over this area the fact the writers keep
bringing this up hints at where this
story may be headed lyme disease is an
illness that affects the nervous system
and typical symptoms include fever
vomiting headache and fatigue and who
vomits sleeps a lot and has headaches
doris even she remarks how it's weird
she throws up considering she should be
past the morning sickness phase of her
pregnancy but here is where it gets even
more interesting another side effect
some may experience from lyme disease is
an allergy to red meats red meats
particularly the blood are needed to
sustain those who take the black pills
with harry and alma both having taken
black pills by the end of episode 2 the
pieces of the puzzle are starting to fit
together we also know that tb karen
steals a baby for belle noir to eat
something will undoubtedly happen where
doris and her baby will be in jeopardy
of being fed on but maybe with her lyme
disease blood it may kill or stop
whomever feasts on her i'm not a hundred
percent sold on this just yet since we
do see harry suck on doris's finger but
there could be a few explanations for
this that have yet to be revealed lyme
disease may also have something to do
with the pale creatures attacking doris
something about her is seen as a threat
hence why she's attacked in broad
daylight and later at night we get a new
ahs intro which doesn't give away too
many clues just a lot of images of
beaches meat black pills and art which
seem to be major motifs of the season
here we see the welcome to provincetown
sign established in 1686. in my trailer
breakdown video which you should check
out if you haven't seen i'll leave a
link to it in the description i
discussed how provincetown's past could
come into play hs loves to do flashbacks
and there might even be a connection to
season five's roanoke since there's even
mention of the pilgrims in the colony
they set up here the gardeners have
taken a rental from the brown family for
the winter in an attempt to get away
from the city and hopefully for harry to
find some inspiration for his
screenwriting career in the third radio
chapter we get an ad for provincetown
rentals which may have been the site
used to find such a place they are
getting these three months free in
exchange for doris redecorating the
place and this is important we'll later
see how doris struggles with her
redecorating and believing she's not
good enough all three members of the
gardner family are artists harry's a
writer alma a musician and doris a
decorator on his way to the market harry
notices these red lights turn on outside
some of the homes we'll also see a
similar light outside bell noirs i
wonder if this is some sort of sign for
the pale creatures not to attack homes
with red lights at the market harry runs
into tuberculosis karen played by sarah
paulson and my god she's great even down
to the f off hair braid the market owner
says she probably doesn't actually have
tb but she definitely has a lot of
diseases and an addiction to drugs could
she have lyme disease here we see this
fox on the beach grabbed by what appears
to be a pale creature it could also be
mickey i'm more inclined not to believe
it's a pale creature since we see the
fox again alive in episode 2 but hey
that could just be an editing error we
learn a bit more about what brought
harry out here to work he's being paid
to rewrite a television pilot and has
three months to do it at the cemetery
alma wonders if any of the people buried
here were pilgrims another hint that we
might be going back in time this season
they're chased off by a pale man and
survived the attack where we're then
introduced to adina porter's character
chief burleson we've seen her in the
season trailer the chief is quick to
brush off the attack as a crazed junkie
in fact 85 percent of the crime in town
is opioid related harry inquires if this
is anything to do with the animalistic
murders that occurred in neighboring
truro where a guy killed his family last
winter the episode also focuses on harry
looking into these murders so it's
possible we may see this in a future
episode here he goes for a run on the
beach where he finds two bodies washed
ashore which one of the detectives says
may be the work of a great white mickey
will later talk about his love for jaws
later on which i thought was fun in the
chapter 3 radio broadcast there are even
mentions of great white attacks we're
getting reports of drownings up and down
the shore and even some great white
attacks but this is more likely the work
of the pale creatures or even bell or
austin we've seen dennis o'hare's
character holden who we have not met yet
come across mutilated remains on a
similar beach in the trailer we still
don't know who this r insignia ring
belongs to the only person with an r as
a first or last name we've met so far is
rose flynn the radio host heard in the
kpcd recordings who likely dies at the
end of the third broadcast but this
appears to be jewelry of someone a
little bit more wealthy so who knows
here he comes home and decides not to
tell his wife about the two bodies he
found washed ashore a bit strange
instead wanting to celebrate life with
her by taking her out to the only
restaurant open in town the muse but she
gets sick and tells him to go enjoy a
drink by himself there telling him to
bring her back a steak or burger since
she's craving red meat new to ahs is
macaulay culkin's mickey a male
prostitute who offers to frontage with
harry it's french for rubbing our dicks
together we're also treated to a musical
number by evan peters and francis
conroy's characters austin and belle
noire both are artists who invite harry
over for a drink bell noir is mentioned
in an ad in chapter 1 of the radio
program known for her best-selling
wildflower series the drought it's a fun
name since belle and austin are always
thirsty for blood bell noir's real name
is sarah cunningham and there is another
cunningham in the ahs universe elias
cunningham played by dennis o'hare in
roanoke and his character is also an
author i'm wondering if there's a
connection here the song they sing
islands in the stream is also named
after a book by famous american novelist
ernest hemingway they sit harry down and
he thinks he's not worthy to be with
them i don't think i'm worthy i'm just a
i'm a crap screenwriter with a bunch of
studio rewrites and a bunch of
busted pilots and this really points at
harry's flaw no wonder he has writer's
block he believes he's a [ __ ] writer why
right only to be proven that you are
[ __ ] that's why he's blocked tv karen
interrupts the evening calling them
bloodsuckers which is also what one of
the guests on the radio show calls an
unknown person who interrupted his
business
that accosted my place of business
yesterday i'm certain you don't have a
phone or hell even a bed but i know
you're listening out there do not come
into my fabric store screaming at my
customers we can assume this is tb karen
when harry arrives home he's attacked by
one of the pale men but is able to
defend himself killing the intruder who
the chief once again downplays as being
a junkie in episode 2 we'll see harry
surrounded by these creatures but this
time they back off is he protected by
bell noir or is it something in the
black pills that he's taking that fends
them off at bill noire's we see she's
been paying for mickey's
services but this also includes feasting
off his blood it also gives her a buzz
since he's on drugs which get
transferred to her in the process we see
that belle has teeth just like the pale
creatures which makes it easier for her
to consume her prey these sharp teeth
were given to her by dr fellman aka
billy lords lark in episode 2 we'll see
belle refer harry to her in order to get
his teeth filed to make eating easier
that tattoo shop is also mentioned in
the radio show as having a great vintage
rack hey tb karen don't go in there all
you'll find are my ex-girlfriends well
she goes dumpster diving anyway when she
gets a call from belle bell supplies tb
with drugs in exchange for favors like
collecting babies for her to feast on
although tb karen says it's not about
the drugs for her it's about getting
bell's protection from the creatures so
it'll be interesting to see if bell has
some sort of control over that bell says
most people would sell their soul for
greatness
i know i did which gives me selling your
soul to the devil type vibes but too
early to know if there's any connection
to that until we finally meet the
chemist we've seen her in the trailer
but not much is known about her other
than she was the one to create the black
pills harry goes over to austin where
he's offered one of these black pills
that will supposedly cure his writer's
block at first harry says no he doesn't
know the side effects and says i don't
like choices you can't come back from it
isn't until he gets a call from ursula
reminding him of the dire situation he's
in vis-a-vis his career that harry
relents and takes one of the pills now
ursula here is played by ahs alum leslie
grossman and appears to be harry's agent
we see in the posters her reading one of
his screenplays we've also seen the
trailers how she teams up with mickey
and wants to know what strange things
are going on in this town she probably
makes her way to p-town when harry
either goes missing or needs her help
and no wonder since there's a lot on the
line for her as well they've got a
netflix deal and movie with joaquin
phoenix at stake the fact she also teams
up with mickey who we see writing
screenplays himself probably means
ursula has the potential to help him get
his movie made and career going i should
also mention with mickey and harry both
being screenwriters it's totally
possible that one of their works becomes
the second part of double feature death
valley and that's how these two are
linked so alma watches her father take
the black pill and gets the idea in her
head that she can become a better artist
like her dad if she takes one too this
is what happens in episode 2 when she
takes a pill in order to improve her
performance of paganini we even get a
brief glimpse of her bowing on stage
hearkening back to her dream of becoming
a famous violinist the first shot of
episode 2 is of a leaky faucet a
metaphor for how harry's creativity is
about to dry up it's in this episode we
see the ups and downs of taking the pill
on the one hand he can write like a
banshee but on the other he becomes
insanely irritable taking his
frustrations out on his wife and
daughter don't be jealous because i
found inspiration and you can't play
[ __ ]
let's not forget how absolutely cocky he
gets this is really good
thanks so now harry begins to lose his
appetite for normal things spitting up a
sandwich and preferring the taste of
blood to satiate this thirsty ventures
off to the market where the owner
somehow knows his writing is going well
based on the amount of meat he's putting
in the cart so there's more to a lot of
these town folk that meets the eye get
it meets the eye
here we see doris creatively blocked in
her design process the first hint that
she too might end up taking a black pill
even though she says to alma there's no
magic pill for greatness sweetheart
while cooking doris cuts herself and
harry can't help but suck the blood
right from her i mean some people are
into kinky stuff but this is over the
line he goes in search of austin for
answers who says only the chemist knows
what's in those black pills we learn
that the pill depletes four of your
body's main minerals from the blood thus
the insatiable urge for it we also
learned that the pill was likely created
by accident after drug users started
experimenting with different drugs after
the market crash of 08. i'm wondering if
this crash has anything to do with tb
karen she says the last time she was
with a man was around 15 years ago
that's about two years off and i'm
really hoping we get a tb karen
flashback to see what caused her to turn
to drugs the black pill also doesn't
work if you don't have any talent to
begin with that's how you get those pale
creatures who austin calls both flesh
phantoms and hacks when harry gets the
call about his writing success he says
to doris we're gonna be red and this
isn't the first time art as just a way
to make money has been brought up austin
says it a lot but what will be their
downfall here is that art isn't about
what makes the most money the only
characters who really love art for what
it truly is is tb karen and mickey it's
about making you
feel this leads me to believe that harry
will likely have a tragic ending unless
he changes and that karen will have a
redemptive one although it's hard to
come back from stealing a baby austin
and bell take harry out to feed they
only target junkies and people who won't
be missed the two of them can live for
about a week off one body bell also says
there are two rules when hunting their
prey one and never feed off anyone in
provincetown and two never take off your
gloves the gloves thing here is really
interesting my mind immediately thinks
it's to avoid fingerprints but there's
gotta be something else here also tb
karen wears gloves too yet she's not one
of these creatures but perhaps that's
just a coincidence one of my favorite
scenes so far occurs between mickey who
lets karen crash at his place they talk
about their dreams as artists and i
thought it was really sweet when karen
learned her painting sold for five
dollars maybe it was just me but i also
got some romantic tension between the
two a love affair which really can't
happen because of all of her diseases
she says she's only contagious if she
kisses or has sex we'll see in the
trailer this scene which looks like the
two of them but we aren't exactly sure
if this is an embrace or one of them
being stabbed well mickey has swiped
some of those black pills from belle and
unlike karen is willing to give them a
try we'll later see him writing like
crazy as a result but this also means
he'll soon have to feed as well harry is
forced to watch as bell kills so they
can feed he feels guilty about this but
belle justifies it by saying that this
person's life doesn't matter since
harry's art will benefit the world much
more than the junkies life ever did
harry gets his teeth done by lark fitted
with caps so that he doesn't look like a
crazy person when gallivanting about
town and while he's out alma takes a
black pill eventually fainting like her
father alma experiences extreme
moodiness telling her mother she doesn't
understand greatness and that she
doesn't want to leave p-town speaking of
pee harry ventures to the dick dock
where locals come for high tide happy
endings and he kills a prostitute to
feed this guy's seen a lot of dead
bodies these last few days doris wakes
up from a nap and can't find her
daughter arguing with harry when she
finds out he let their daughter go for a
walk on her own just days after they
were attacked in broad daylight doris
ends up finding elm at the cemetery
feasting on a squirrel as other pale
creatures watch on if it's the black
pill which holds back these creatures it
makes sense why alma was not attacked
i'm also unsure if there's any
significance to the brandon newman
soldier grave in front of her we do know
there is something about the cemetery
that attracts these creatures we've seen
in the trailer a shot of one of the
creatures holding flowers with a woman
kneeling before him and a mystery female
creature in the dark which a few people
have guessed might be doris i think in
large part to the nightgown but it's a
little bit different than doris's but
what do you think i'm absolutely loving
this slow burn first two episodes and i
want to hear all your thoughts and
theories in the comments below be sure
to like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can always follow me on
twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you